you're watching the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages
in the next half an hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines
with paper crea and harry cole the
political editors of the daily mirror
and the sun and they'll be with us right
through until midnight
so let's see then what's on the front of
the newspapers the guardian
reporting that the relaxation is going
ahead
despite some of the government's
scientific advisors warning the move
could lead
to a mini wave with as many as 200
deaths a day
similar take from the times which
reports that thousands of people could
be admitted to hospital
every day the daily mail asks how long
the lifting of all restrictions will
last
after the prime minister warned the
rules could return the delhi express
also focuses on boris johnson's plea for
the public to go easy
despite the removal of the covert laws
while the daily telegraph leads on the
government urging venues to use vaccine
passports for mass events
according to the eye 3.8 million
clinically vulnerable people are being
told they must avoid contact
with individuals who haven't had both
doses of the vaccine
advice which critics claim effectively
keeps shielding
in place focusing on the business angle
the ft
reports the relaxation means it's now
companies who will have to enforce any
covert measures
rather than the government meanwhile
we've got your back the sun leads on the
racist abuse
received by england football players
following sunday's euros final
while the daily mirror features an image
of an injured police officer
and condemns both the racist and violent
scenes after the match
england star tyron ming's criticism of
the home secretary pretty patel who he
accuses of
encouraging the abuse is the front of
the metro while the star declares it is
coming home but they talk about the sun
as it's predicted to be quite hot which
is some relief to all of us because the
weather is extraordinary
um so pippa crea harry kohler here two
stories i guess in town
tonight and harry not perhaps
the headlines um that the government had
wanted
on pronouncing um that freedom day
so-called will go ahead
yeah a set of front pages had so
depressing no one no one wanted to
no one wanted today to be like this
today um the only thing that seems to
come home
i think is a massive reality check um
from the government scientists
yet again something's happened in the
last week um
if you remember this time last week
boris johnson was
a personal responsibility robert jenner
was talking about ripping off masks
sajid javid was talking about
um the time of personal responsibility
you know the end in sight
we can we you know we can do this this
is terminus day
and it feels to me like since those
cases have crept up over the week
um and the hospitalizations have started
to take up
and a small increase in in deaths but
nothing compared to where we've been
previously
in in in waves of covet there just seems
to be a bit of a
bit of a shift of of tone um
freedom day yes but once again buried in
the small printers
uh instead of as being a terminus day
and an ending of all restrictions
government reserves the right to slam
slam us back into lockdown
as and when uh they choose so you know
everyone was in a bad mood as it was
this morning and i just think everyone's
going to be a bit weary after reading
tomorrow's papers
again because things we thought had gone
away vaccine passports
um you know are back
and actually you know if i was running a
nightclub or a pub or
or a sports business i would be pretty
livid tonight having
you know been promised that all this was
going to suddenly find out a week before
so-called freedom day the onus is now on
us to make sure it all happens
yeah indeed so um we'll take a look at
some of that scientific data which has
probably informed the government in
some of the other newspapers but to the
impact of the change in tone
the telegraph you've mentioned harry
vaccine passports
um yet yes it is down to personal and
corporate responsibility
but actually we are all being urged to
be far more cautious
with things like vaccine passports it
seems coming in for
venues like nightclubs pippa yes and you
know i have to pick harry up on
suggesting that something has happened
in the last week that suddenly changed
the government's mind i mean we sat here
last week and talked about all of this
and even then it was clear
that cases were rising hospitalizations
thankfully
in a very uh you know the numbers the
rises were very small and continue to be
sort of slow and incremental rises
but it was clear then and there were
plenty of scientists then warning
including sage
that the government's plans for
so-called freedom day
as it was billed um were potentially
going to be problematic and that despite
the fact that the legal restrictions
were being lifted
there was still going to be a
requirement for many of the measures to
stay in place
for people not to rush back to work for
people to carry on wearing
masks and while that shift in tone has
definitely happened this week it's you
know i forget
forgive me for being a bit a bit uh
skeptical about some of the reasons
behind it
yes the data has continued to go the
wrong way but the vaccination rollout
continues but there's also been also
quite a lot of public polling which
suggests that the public wasn't
necessarily
on board with some of what the
government had been suggesting face
masks in particular
wearing them in in the transport network
and and in shops there was real public
support for continuing that
and it kind of feels like we've been
here before many times
of course the difference this time is
that there's a vaccination program and
we all hope against hope that that means
that
this lifting of restrictions uh can
continue
and and is does end up becoming
permanent but
you know the data seems to suggest the
contrary and
you know um it's um
how many times have we sat here weeks
after being sort of made promises about
about lifting or spending christmas with
our families or easter with our families
or being able to travel abroad in the
summer or whatever and it hasn't come to
pass
and it's hard to escape the feeling that
you know here we are again
yes and certainly uh over in france too
in a televised address president macron
said that anyone who wanted to go to a
restaurant shopping mall or hospital or
get on a train
or a plane would need to show um a
covert 19 pass equivalent i suppose of
what we're hearing
denmark as well restaurants public
events require a digital pass
some german states require the same for
restaurants et cetera et cetera i mean
we're not we're not alone in thinking
about this but it was
it was kind of thrown out wasn't it the
old vaccine passports idea
um are you supportive of it harry or
is it is it is stepping on our liberty
once again
i'm not i'm not going to get swivel lied
about us and a ditch if
you know if it people are comfortable
going into a venue a big stadium saying
like last night
um i've certainly used it to go to a
couple of the pilot events
over the last few weeks it's very easy
it's not some great infringement with
your civil liberties to be asked to take
a test
um before you choose to actively pass
ache in a in a public activity
if you don't want to do it don't go um
where i think it does get a bit
ridiculous is this idea that we're going
to need
and you know it ever can be practical
to you know have to display it to go in
and out of apartment and out of a shop i
think
there's a there's definitely a line to
be drawn there the government reserved
the right to be to to
roll it out more in the winter in a bid
to keep things open rather than going
back into a lockdown
so we'll see where that gets to um
on the you know on the on on the great
narrative pushes because going back to
where we were before
i should say freedom day you know top
line is it is going ahead
it does feel to me like there may have
been a bit of a pact done
with the um between the sort of
ministers and the medics to get them to
all
over to over the line for excuse me for
july 19th to go ahead next week
in the fact that actually what what the
government really wanted to do is share
a lot of this
legislation off of the off of the
statute book that was what was making
people quite uncomfortable this
continuing
legal enforcement of things and actually
the price the pack they've done with the
medics is actually yes they will make it
sound very gloomy
in order to do that but at the end of
the day it is now
it is now down to people's choice it is
down to personal responsibility
so it's sort of it's more about the
messaging and actually
should should the restrictions you know
should things get better should they've
actually roll
out improve things as it appears to show
they are doing
it is doing sorry it'll actually be a
lot easier to open up now without having
to actually change the law
um rather guidance is a lot easier to
change than legislation
yes and certainly the daily express one
of those newspapers that picked up on
that change in messaging
uh green light for freedom get but go
easy uh boss johnson once again quoting
jonathan van tam
don't tear the pants out of it uh we'll
we'll remember that moment
uh daily mail as well freedom but for
how long uh pm confirms unlocking on
july the 19th but warns curbs could be
back
and this is certainly something that the
the minutes from
sage or the or the papers from sage have
revealed today too
firm shouldn't order staff into work um
and the sage modelling suggesting we've
got to go easy for
for the next five months for a long time
not just the next few weeks not just for
the
for the summer that cases will be
peaking way down the line pippa
yeah i don't know where this idea has
come from that
suddenly it's all going to be over and i
i guess a lot of people kind of thought
that because the government promised
them that we'd have this unlocking on
july the 19th so that meant we
won our battle against covid and of
course that's not the case
in this country and it's certainly not
the case globally and we still have
large numbers of people i mean the
vaccine roller is
absolutely amazing but we still have
large numbers of people that haven't had
a second dose there are concerns about
uptake amongst the young
which is in part why they're talking
about this vaccine passport idea and
even
suggesting it might have to be mandatory
later in the year if
if uptake is is not as swift as they'd
hoped
and of course children haven't been the
decision hasn't been made by the jcbi
of where the children are going to be
vaccinated or not in addition to that
there's many people many millions of
people that are for whatever reason
clinically vulnerable that either aren't
able to have the vaccine or
um have had it but the efficacy is much
much lower than it would be in a in a
sort of otherwise healthy person
so um you know it's it kind of feels
that
um while the government is
making this decision for us to to go
ahead now there are still lots of
unknowns and
crucially while up until this point
we've been able to
scientists have been able to model quite
a lot around hospital admissions
and unfortunate deaths and case numbers
it's
going to be harder going forward because
it's very difficult to model human
behavior
and we just don't know yet whether
people will follow
um follow the guidance as harry rightly
says guidance is easier to to implement
for the government but it's also easier
to ignore for the public
so you know i think we're going to the
next few the next few weeks are
going to be incredibly telling yes
you're i mean you're going gone harriet
sorry
i must say some of the numbers though
that have been floating around this
afternoon the times i think pick up on
this idea that 5 000 people a day are
going to be hospitalized
um does seem to be at the little end of
the
of the of the wacky wacky numbers scale
um this you know
the worst case scenario scenarios being
thrown around that have been way out
before
and actually even at the peak of the so
even the peak of the second wave in
the darkest days of january i don't
think i've got over more than about 4
223 people i'll just look that up um
very specific on one day um and that was
without a vaccine roll out
so i don't think the the case numbers
you'd have to get to
with the with the broken or the or the
nearly broken or they're severely
weakened as they say link between
hospitalizations and cases that the
vaccine has afforded us
you know you're getting into sort of
hundreds of thousands of cases every day
to get anywhere near that so
i do think that perhaps uh in this kind
of battle that's going on behind the
scenes some some of the modeling has got
slightly uh
you know sort of ott and i do wonder
what what effect that is having on the
on
on the mood yeah uh there is the times
then thousands in hospital each day
uh the figure was up to four thousand
eight hundred people a day could be
admitted to hospital
with covid if england rushes back to
normality
and the guardian as well with another
figure on the front uh
the promise to lift restrictions the
paper says despite fears of
this exit wave that chris whittie talked
about with 200 deaths today they talked
about one
between 100 and 200 deaths a day um but
it is the delta variant we're talking
about very quickly pippa
um it does rise exponentially as we know
but as you
said the uncertainty is because they
don't know how we are going to
behave my question is having said you
can go for it
and we've seen that with the euros in
scotland and in england
can the genie go back in the bottle
it's difficult isn't it because
obviously everyone is delighted to be
able to
sort of resume an element of normal life
and you know it's it's
i was at wembley last night and it was
it's great to
be part of that sort of big crowd event
again but then
you know rammed on the tube afterwards
with a whole load of people that weren't
wearing face masks
and uh you know in some of the crowds uh
outside wembley um it was quite you know
it's hard not to feel rather anxious
about it frankly
um i think it's going to be very
difficult if you say to people
resume your normal life again and you're
not going to face any sanctions if you
don't and
and you know we've all been waiting so
long for this freedom to then suddenly
turn around and say hey guys
you know stop the party um you know
bring it in
it's all been billed as freedom day
that's number 10 that decided to
to brief it as such um you can't
suddenly say no actually it's caution
day
yeah absolutely sorry to button we'll
talk about the football after the break
if that's okay with you but um
uh we're interesting to hear your
thoughts on how the game unraveled uh
coming up then the home secretary
accused of hypocrisy over her stance on
racism
in football we'll discuss that next
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now
pippa create and harry cole welcome back
to both of you another big story in town
obviously is the football
and of course the repercussions of what
we saw
the metro for example england star slams
pretty patel the home secretary
and uh the sun as well we're with you
boys
uh inside as well southgate attacks
racists over
unforgivable abuse um it's it's been
quite
at 24 hours hasn't it harry
yeah yeah this time last night it was
still
um it was still alive just about um
yeah yeah the sort of inevitable fallout
of a nation sort of waking up in despair
and also waking up to the absolute sewer
uh
that is um that has hit uh through those
three poor lads who who
stood up there took their shot and and
sadly missed but didn't deserve
the the fallout from um what is you know
a very shameful um sort of repercussions
with the online racism
gary southgate attempted to say that
some of this was you know obviously from
foreign uh
foreign internet users and looks quite
coordinated but
you can't escape the fact and he said we
cannot escape the fact that some of this
was was you know nominally english
england fans but
um as many a player and a politician is
queued up to say
um you know you're not real fans if
you're doing this
however um the political fallout isn't
quite done there because tyron ming's
tonight has had
quite a hefty swing at pretty patel
who described taking the knee as uh
gesture politics
and then has come out tonight to slam
the internet firms and the
and the and the and the racist fans for
attacking the players and tyron means
that actually hold on
you don't get to do both of these things
um so i think she's gonna have quite an
awkward few days actually
as um as some of the comments made
before
the uh before the the before ball was
even kicked in this tournament was
um were were made and you remember the
government slightly got us up into a bit
of a mess before this tournament where
uh you know boris johnson to be fair he
never said you know go and crack on boo
the fans he said you know we should be
cheering not booing
a line here he lifted from the sun but
bigger hour coming
i'll let people get a word inside sorry
too sorry to finish you there
harry pippa thank you both see you at
11.